[Music]
foreign
Fields welcome
I am
going to make a very good assistant no
he's evil we will protect you you have
the word of the most trusted institution
on Earth the Catholic Church
[Music]
on purpose in life is to serve me now
let's see
I just want a normal life again
[Applause]
let me explain I work for Dracula Count
Dracula
it's the real Dracula some call me the
dark one
other is the Lord of death so you bring
them people to eat well I do other stuff
like what washes cake no the Cape is dry
clean only strictly yeah I will wear
this it's flying yeah
I've got nothing such a bad guy but
you're never really gonna be free until
you face him I will no longer tolerate
abuse
[Music]
will suffer because you betrayed me we
have to stop him Before Sunset
[Music]
I deserve happiness and I take full
charge
[Music]
you know when something crazy happens
and someone's like it's okay I've seen
way worse everything I saw you do today
is gonna be my way worse it's my least
favorite part of the job
[Music]
foreign